saqueos manifestaciones bloqueos y
enfrentamientos el inicio de año ha sido
explosivo para méxico se han producido
muertes y las detenciones se cuentan por
cientos pero que ha provocado semejante
ola de violencia los que nos estáis
viendo desde méjico lo sabéis bien ha
sido lo que se conoce como el gasolinazo
y para hablarnos de ello vamos a contar
con la colaboración de nuestro buen
amigo antonio tadeo periodista mexicano
qué tal amigos de visual política así es
en esta ocasión hablaremos del
gasolinazo en mexico para todos aquellos
que quieren seguir la actualidad de
mexico podéis ver los informativos de
antonio desde la página de facebook de
itv line
el gobierno ha decretado para 2017 un
incremento récord en el precio de la
gasolina de casi el 20 por ciento
el pueblo de mexico está furioso no solo
por la subida de los carburantes sino
también por la sensación de que las
élites políticas les están engañando
hechos violentos ocurrieron en baja
california como ejemplo de ello en donde
civiles se enfrentaron con elementos de
la policía federal que trataron de
desalojar un bloqueo en las
instalaciones de la petrolera mexicana
pemex en los saqueos hubo de todos desde
golpes hasta balazos sin dejar de lado
la histeria colectiva de la población
quienes realizaron guardias vecinales en
fundando palos piedras machetes y hasta
armas de fuego para defender sus barrios
en este vídeo vamos a explicar qué ha
ocurrido y lo vamos a hacer por dos
motivos primero porque sin lugar a dudas
es la noticia hispana más importante con
la que comienza 2017 y segundo porque
nos lo habéis pedido ha sido
impresionante una locura en los últimos
días nos habéis enviado cientos
probablemente miles de mensajes y
comentarios pidiéndonos que hablemos de
ello así que vamos allá
[Música]
el gasolinazo lo primero que tenemos que
tener en cuenta es que el sector del
petróleo en méxico no es un mercado
libre sí es cierto como veremos hay en
marcha una reforma para abrirlo a la
competencia pero de momento pemex la
petrolera estatal mantiene el monopolio
y por tanto el gobierno sigue tomando
todas las grandes decisiones y cuál ha
sido su última gran decisión pues
incrementar en 2017 el precio de la
gasolina en hasta un 20 por ciento el
mayor incremento de los últimos 20 años
que se dice pronto y claro esto ha sido
un golpe durísimo para muchas familias
un bombazo para su presupuesto pero
porque se ha tomado una medida tan
impopular en todas estas manifestaciones
existe un común denominador un culpable
un villano favorito' como el de la
película su nombre enrique peña nieto de
quien dicen que el término de soberanía
nacional y conflicto de intereses no
tienen significado alguno en su
administración el presidente de mexico
enrique
nieto y su gobierno afirman que esta
subida se debe exclusivamente a que al
precio internacional del petróleo y de
la gasolina han subido mucho porque
subió entonces el precio de la gasolina
porque en el último año en todo el mundo
el precio del petróleo aumentó cerca de
60 por ciento así que la pregunta que
tenemos que hacernos es ese esto verdad
pues a tenor de los datos sí lo es en
2016 el precio del barril del petróleo
west texas intermediate que podemos
considerar de referencia para méxico
subió aproximadamente un 50 por ciento
[Música]
y claro como es evidente si el petróleo
sube la gasolina también lo hace vamos a
ver qué ha ocurrido en eeuu que es el
principal suministrador de gasolina para
metro si habéis escuchado bien méxico es
una potencia petrolera pero tiene que
importar más del 60 por ciento de la
gasolina que consume y cada vez más es
decir en métodos más llanos méxico vende
las naranjas al vecino de al lado y al
mismo vecino le compra jugo de naranja
pero mucho más caro eso es lo que pasa
con la gasolina en este país a los
gobiernos mexicanos les ha importado un
pimiento o sea nada eso de desarrollar
una industria energética independiente y
competitiva el caso es que este es el
gráfico de cómo ha evolucionado durante
el precio por galón de la gasolina
normal en eeuu podemos ver que el precio
ha subido algo más del 20 por ciento
así que aparentemente enrique peña
nieto- estaría en lo cierto pero esperad
un momento amigos porque hay algo más y
en este caso me dirijo al excelentísimo
presidente don enrique peña nieto
señor presidente usted no nos está
diciendo toda la verdad el pueblo
mexicano no está animado solo porque la
gasolina haya subido un 20 por ciento
esta señora ha sido la gota que ha
colmado el vaso señor presidente durante
su mandato la gasolina ha subido casi un
50 por ciento y es más cara que los
mismísimos eeuu algo no está funcionando
señor la responsabilidad de peña nietos
cuando peña nieto llegó al poder se
encontró con que la gasolina en méxico
era subsidiada por el estado es verdad
que la anterior presidente felipe
calderón ya había reducido
sustancialmente el subsidio pero éste
continuaba existiendo y la verdad
subvencionar la gasolina es una de las
peores cosas que pueden hacer los
gobiernos el estado gasta muchísimo
dinero
la subvención va a parar mayormente a
las personas con más recursos y encima
se incentivan modelos económicos y
hábitos de consumo que gastan muchísima
gasolina un buen ejemplo son los coches
que utiliza la gente en méxico gran
parte son coches usados importa
desde eeuu estos coches tienen unos
motores enormes que consumen muchísima
gasolina claro cuando la gasolina es muy
barata a nadie le importa ahorrar pero
ahora tienen la oportunidad de abrir la
carretera las autoridades reportes
bloqueos carreteros marchas cierre de
gasolinerías y plantones en
instalaciones de pemex esto explica que
méxico prácticamente queme gasolina su
consumo per cápita es superior al de
países como españa alemania francia o
por ejemplo más del doble que el de
brasil ahí es nada
pues el pueblo se está cansando y os
preguntaréis entonces por qué se
subvencionan los combustibles pues casi
siempre para comprar votos
el caso es que donde enrique peña nieto-
terminó con esta política en 2014 algo
que en principio parece buena verdad
pues el problema es que por aquel
entonces los ingresos del gobierno por
la exportación de petróleo estaban
cayendo un montón y a peña nieto no se
le ocurrió nada mejor que compensarlo
con más impuestos muchos más impuestos
en concreto en las gasolinas de méxico
casi el 40 por ciento del precio de hoy
son impuestos
cuando el precio del petróleo estaba por
los suelos pues estos impuestos parecían
pesar menos pero cuando el petróleo sube
está muy bien haber eliminado las
subvenciones pero fijar de forma tan
repentina unos impuestos tan altos ha
supuesto un castigo enorme para las
familias mexicanas sobre todo cuando
encima están perdiendo tanto poder
adquisitivo por la mala situación
económica el poder adquisitivo que hay
un 11 por ciento en los últimos cuatro
años así que señor presidente cuando le
quiera contar al pueblo lo que ha
ocurrido por favor
cuéntale todo hoy en día enrique peña
nieto- registra el nivel de popularidad
más baja de un presidente desde que
méxico se registra la popularidad del
mandatario esto desde 1995 y ojo la más
baja en la historia de credibilidad en
la clase política
ahora bien muchos de los críticos la
mayoría de ellos tal vez tampoco se
salvan
la reforma energética
en 2013 el presidente peña nieto- puso
en marcha la que era una de sus mayores
promesas electorales la reforma
energética que entre otros aspectos
contemplaba liberalizar el sector del
petróleo es decir permitir que nuevas
empresas compitan con pemex
hoy muchos denuncian que esta reforma es
la culpable del gasolinazo lo que
sencillamente como hemos visto no es
cierto fijaros amigos de visual política
méxico es una potencia petrolera pero
importa la mayor parte de la gasolina
que consumen además como no se ha
invertido lo suficiente a pesar de
contar con grandes yacimientos cada vez
produce menos petróleo y por si fuera
poco pemex la compañía estatal de
petróleos propiedad del gobierno que ha
operado en régimen de monopolio está en
quiebra sólo conocemos un caso igual de
desastroso el de pedevesa en venezuela
una de sus primeras políticas fue el
llamado sistema de democratización del
empleo que implementó en la empresa
pedevesa que es la compañía estatal de
venezuela gran parte del problema ha
sido que pemex en vez de utilizar los
recursos generados para invertir y
mejorar sus capacidades ha sido
literalmente saqueada por los diferentes
gobiernos para financiar un gasto
corriente y encima ha sido un poco de
corrupción y clientelismo vamos que no
se puede continuar así y aún hay más en
los últimos tiempos el tipo de cambio
del peso méxico
frente al dólar estadounidense está
sufriendo muchísimo lo que por sí mismo
también es una mala noticia para el
mercado de combustibles que como hemos
dicho depende en gran medida de las
importaciones de eeuu este disparo que
ha tenido la moneda mexicana hasta estos
niveles de depreciación en lo que va del
año del 13 punto 71 por ciento y aquí
una mala noticia amigos los impuestos la
mala situación financiera en el gobierno
mexicano el desastre de pemex y el tipo
de cambio sólo auguran precios de la
gasolina más elevados aún así que amigos
mexicanos vigilar bien vuestra cartera
por cierto a todos los amigos que nos
estáis viendo desde méjico queremos
enviar un mensaje especiales de visual
político donald trump ha insultado
gravemente a méxico e incluso ha tratado
de humillar a vuestro pueblo con su
amenaza de obligados a pagar su muro de
la vergüenza sin embargo ni lo ha
conseguido ni lo va a conseguir queremos
que sepáis que contáis con toda nuestra
solidaridad apoyo y cariño y tener
presente que el mundo de hoy presenta
muchas opciones para no tener que
depender de nadie ni siquiera de eeuu
méxico es una nación soberana y libre
nuestros políticos debería olvidarlo
nunca bueno amigos espero que este vídeo
os haya resultado interesante si ha sido
así y queréis que hablemos más de méxico
darle al botón de like i suscribiros al
canal para estar atentos a nuestros
vídeos por cierto si queréis saber por
qué china está haciéndose con
latinoamérica hacer clic aquí un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]